si los 27 han llegado hoy a un acuerdo
para poder reducir el consumo de gas
hasta un 15 por ciento de momento este
plan va a ser voluntario comienza el 1
de agosto está previsto que dure
aproximadamente 8 meses pero este plan y
este objetivo del 15 por ciento puede
volverse obligatorio si desde luego hay
un peligro real de que rusia acabe
cortando el suministro de gas al cubo
europeo tal y como cada vez parece más
posible en un principio los países
europeos no les había gustado esta
propuesta de la comisión europea de un
recorte obligatorio el 15% pero hoy sí
que ha sido posible el acuerdo ya que
este contiene numerosas excepciones por
ejemplo para aquellos países con falta
de infraestructuras lo que es un guiño a
islas como malta o como irlanda a la
península ibérica que también alega que
no puede exportar el gas o también a
aquellos países que no están conectados
con la red eléctrica europea como los
países bálticos como he dicho habrá
flexibilidad para desde luego poder
adaptar este objetivo del 15 por ciento
y con este acuerdo ahora la unión
europea quiere dar un mensaje de unidad
a rusia